hello everybody and welcome to Episode
number 16 of my road to one bill series
uh I know it's been quite a while since
the last episode but uh kind of a lot
has happened in between the two episodes
uh my account got hacked I got it back
and uh or just the Christmas holidays
and just a couple other things I just
haven't had as much time to play as I'd
like and there was no point pushing an
episode with no content uh but for today
we're definitely going to work on skills
mostly so uh we've kind of had a bit of
a change of plan I think we're going to
go for the lunar spell book uh before we
get the prerequisites for zra there's a
couple really cool money makers that I
want to try on the lunar spell book also
I've just never had a secondary spell
book before so it'll be kind of nice to
get it and we still need about 10 magic
levels realistically before we can
really do Zara and that that's going to
take a little while so going to go for
lunar for that we need uh to get
Crafting up our wood cutting and
unfortunately our mining levels which
we'll need to do uh get up to 60 so we
probably going to do motherload M but
anyway we're going to figure that out
and let's jump into the episode psych uh
we're actually just going to get some
Fletching levels first and the
background behind this is I need these
Fletching levels for my money-making
guide I made about a week ago and I
thought I might as well just get the
levels on my um the main account I play
which is my flipping osrs my road to un
build account uh what we're going for is
the uh Diamond tip animen type bolts at
level 65 cuz you can actually get about
1 mil an hour in profit assuming the
margin's good and yeah we just hit 60
let's go for 65 so we're just about to
hit 65 we're making maple long bows it
really didn't take too long and there we
go 65 and uh I won't really show the
method cuz I do have a full video on it
uh link will be in the description for
that that distraction as side we'll
actually jump into the progress I was
talking about so we're starting off with
the worst skill by far which at least I
think is mining we only have level 18
mining so we have a long ways to go uh
for lunar Hy you need 60 mining uh the
majority of that we're going to do at
the motherload mine because we will need
the gem bag and the coal bag I think I
get from it and yeah so that's my plan
anyway wow I just hit 20 and all
skills a great accomplishment guys I
don't know why it took like four months
to do but whatever there is level 25
mining only took like 3 minutes or so we
just need another five mining levels and
then we can actually head to the motherl
mine which will be a little more AFK
okay all right so we're just about to
hit 30 mining which I am super happy
about because power mining iron is
possibly my least favorite thing to do
in RuneScape it's uh boring and kind of
Click intensive to be honest once you at
least get higher mining levels anyway
there's 30 so we can head over to the
motherload mine and uh not have to pay
attention so much all right I like this
Mor already uh while it's not as AFK as
wood cutting uh you definitely don't
have to click every single time
uh to remine another ore on top of that
we're getting a little bit of money
probably like only 20 or 30k an hour at
least until we get gold ore all right so
here's a nice donation of 10K blue
feathers uh so unfortunately when my uh
account got hacked they took the blue
feathers which is [__] such a dick
move like who even cares they seriously
cleaned my bank like I feel like they
used to bot or something cuz like
everything in value was gone but uh
thanks to Leu anyway there level 35
mining um nothing too interesting to
report here uh I am watching
Interstellar in the background pretty
good movie for those who haven't seen it
it's pretty long though it's like 3
hours kind of sad actually uh but still
pretty good so you're maybe wondering
where this 33 mil is coming from and PK
myth is the owner of G
tracker they so graciously actually just
helped me out quite a bit I did buy
about 30 mil worth of bonds uh but they
did kind of give me the rest back for
kind of making my own mistake so it's
really awesome and again I want to thank
everyone who offered me money it just
felt a little weird after um my account
got hacked people lost money because of
it I didn't want to ask um you guys to
give me anymore it felt a little better
coming from what is essentially my
sponsor uh because they for one have a
interest in me continuing my videos and
it just I don't know it made more sense
to me but I really want to thank them
again they didn't have to do that I
didn't expect them to do that at all uh
so it really helped me get back on my
feet and again thank you for everyone
actually offered me money and yeah let's
jump back into
the it's kind of weird into the video
all right there's 40 mining we can
finally wield the Run nope never mind we
can't why did they make it 41 mining I
why not just 40 anyway One More Level
and we get the Rune pickaxe but uh we're
getting there
all right there we go we got a rune
pickaxe uh which will kind of help a
little bit you can see I'm slowly buying
back these blue feathers I'm definitely
going to invest some of this money back
into the feathers because like it was an
awesome collection it was just starting
off too uh but we'll go ahead and buy
some more of those and uh they do have
an 8K buying limit though which is kind
of weird there is 45 mining only 15 more
levels uh we could mine Granite but I've
heard it's extremely inefficient until
you're higher level we're better off
power mining iron with which I do hate
so I'm sure Granite wouldn't be any
better uh but yeah I think we're going
to take a break from Mining and maybe
get our wood cutting or crafting level
up going to kind of cycle through these
to keep it a little more interesting for
me mostly and
yourself all right so next up we're
going to get our wood cutting up we do
need 55 for lunar diplomacy and I
definitely like wood cutting more than
mining uh just more AFK more XP per hour
more nostalgic value I just remember
talking to people wood cutting reminding
I was just hating myself the whole time
pretty much much all right we're just
about to hit 41 wood cutting so we can
upgrade to our run ax which we actually
have in the inventory and we'll do do
wellow straight to 55 I think is the
best way uh we could start cutting
Maples but I've heard it's not very good
XP uh we actually got a surprise on the
bird nest I wasn't really paying
attention at all and uh but they do drop
on the ground and the seed ones actually
can drop pretty expensive seeds so
there's 45 wood cutting um I'm just kind
of curious to see what we actually get
from these bird nests uh from first one
is a palm tree seed that's pretty good
that's like 60k that's uh [__] and
that's not very good either all right
we're coming up on 50 wood cutting and
we got some more bird nests to open and
I've never seen that one with a egg in
it so I'm kind of interested to see what
that is for uh we'll look it up and come
back to you later but uh there we go 50
wood cutting five more wood cutting
levels needed and uh we're going to
probably work on our crafting and Fir
making too so we might take a break from
this as well um um but yeah it's a bird
egg interesting uh you guys know what
that is for cuz it's definitely not
tradable interesting so we left uh some
offers in for the malediction Ward uh
overnight and most of them did complete
so what we're going to do is take those
three pieces combine him into a Mal
adiction Ward and we're going to get
about 200k on each combination also
about 400k we'll get there so not too
bad on top of that we're going to sell
off the RAR weeds we have from doing our
farm runs another 1.8 mil we we're going
to add to our cash stack there probably
900 to 1 mil in profit so uh pretty
happy with that we're going to take
these out and uh go ahead and combine
them and then we'll get back to our
Skilling all right there we go mal
addiction Ward combined that was an easy
200k uh it did take a while for the
offer to complete to be fair uh but when
it did uh it sells pretty quickly so
still works
guys uh so we actually got to 45 fir
making unfortunately the recording got
corrupted uh which is too bad mean you
guys missed out on some really extremely
entertaining firemaking content uh so
you're not going to get that back
unfortunately uh but uh we'll survive I
guess so now we're on to I think Maple
logs uh which will be a bit more XP per
hour we just need to get to 49 so it's
not that far realistically and yeah
we'll just do Maple probably another 10
minutes and then that'll be another
requirement out of the
way all right so we're just about to hit
another fir making milestone that is
going to be 49 and that will be enough
for lunar diplomacy so we'll leave fir
making for now next up we're definitely
going to work on some crafting levels
and we're going to try to find a
somewhat cost effective way to do that
because it can be extremely pricey so
we've decided to go with uncut
sapphires uh because we're only actually
going to lose about 100 GP on each uh
cut I don't know and uh then we'll take
that to 46 from there we're going to do
unpowered orbs until like
like 55 or something like that and then
from there we could do uh the battle
stabs again they're pretty pricey or we
could even find something else to do but
there is 40 crafting and we'll get all
the way to 46 just from these uncut
Sapphires and then we'll decide all
right there is 46 crafting we can now uh
create orbs uh which will be a pro
possibly a bit cheaper than this and I
think they give a bit more experience as
well all right guys so we're just about
to wrap up the episode uh but I thought
I would do a pretty full recap on my
bank status as well as my skills uh so
for the skills most notably our total
level is up to about
1170 uh we got our mining to 46 our
Fletching to 66 and crafting to 46 and
wood cutting to 50 hopefully next
episode we can get all the prerequisites
for lunar diplomacy done and hopefully
get the quest done itself cuz there's a
couple moneymaking methods I want to try
and um now for my bank status uh We've
have about the same amount of cash as
when my account got hacked uh 117k blue
feathers we bought a couple most of our
items back not everything uh let's see
here we have uh the toxic blowpipe the
Trident back and so there's not a whole
lot of changes in my bank uh besides
just a bunch of little petty things
being gone like my Cannon haven't
replaced that yet uh but we have 13 mil
so we're not really left with a huge
deficit off of where we left off and
yeah I hope you enjoyed the episode I
know it was mostly Skilling so we'll try
to vary it up in the next one but until
then I hope you guys have a wonderful
day and I'll will see you guys in the
next episode
[Music]